In this segment, we develop
the inclusion-exclusion
formula, which is a beautiful
generalization of a formula
that we have seen before.
Let us look at this
formula and remind
ourselves what it says.
If we have two sets, A1 and A2,
and we're interested in
the probability of their union,
how can we find it?
We take the probability of the
first set, we add to it the
probability of the second set,
but then we realize that by
doing so we have double counted
this part of the diagram.
And so we need to correct for
that and we need to subtract
the probability of this
intersection.
And that's how this formula
comes about.
Can we generalize this thinking,
let's say, to the
case of three events?
Suppose that we have three
events, A1, A2, and A3.
And we want to calculate the
probability of their union.
We first start by adding
the probabilities of
the different sets.
But then we realize that, for
example, this part of the
diagram has been
counted twice.
It shows up once inside the
probability of A1 and once
inside the probability of A2.
So, for this reason, we need
to make a correction and we
need to subtract the
probability of this
intersection.
Similarly, subtract the
probability of that
intersection and of this one.
So we subtract the probabilities
of these
intersections.
But, actually, the intersections
are not just
what I drew here.
The intersections also
involve this part.
So now, let us just focus on
this part of the diagram here.
A typical element that belongs
to all three of the sets will
show up once here, once
here and once there.
But it will also show up in all
of these intersections.
And so it shows up three times
with a plus sign, three times
with a minus sign, which means
that these elements will not
to be counted at all.
In order to count them, we
need to add one more term
which is the probability of the
three way intersection.
So this is the formula for the
probability of the union of
three events.
It has a rationale similar to
this formula, and you can
convince yourself that it is
a correct formula by just
looking at the different pieces
of this diagram and
make sure that each one of them
is accounted properly.
But instead of working in terms
of such a picture, let
us think about a more
formal derivation.
And the formal derivation will
use a beautiful trick.
Namely, indicator functions.
So here is the formula that
we want to establish.
And let us remind ourselves what
indicator functions are.
To any set or event,
we can associate
an indicator function.
Let's say that this
is the set Ai.
We're going to associate an
indicator function, call it
Xi, which is equal to 1 when
the outcome is inside this
set, and it's going to be 0 when
the outcome is outside.
What is the indicator function
of the complement?
The indicator function of the
complement is 1 minus the
indicator of the event.
Why is this?
If the outcome is in the
complement, then Xi is equal
to 0, and this expression
is equal to 1.
On the other hand, if the
outcome is inside Ai, then the
indicator function will be equal
to 1 and this quantity
is going to be equal to 0.
If we have the intersection of
two events, Ai and Aj, what is
their indicator function?
It is Xi times Xj.
This expression is equal to 1,
if and only if, Xi is equal to
1 and Xj is equal to 1, which
happens, if and only if, the
outcome is inside Ai
and also inside Aj.
Now, what about the indicator
of the intersection of the
complements?
Well, it's an intersection.
So the associated indicator
function is going to be the
product of the indicator
function of the first set,
which is 1 minus Xi times the
indicator function of the
second set, which
is 1 minus Xj.
And finally, what
is the indicator
function of this event?
Here we remember De
Morgan's Laws.
De Morgan's Laws tell us that
the complement of this set--
the complement of a union--
is the intersection of
the complements.
So this event here is the
complement of that event.
And, therefore, the associated
indicator function is going to
be 1 minus this expression.
And if we were dealing with
more than two sets--
and here we had, for example,
three way intersections--
you would get the product
of three terms.
And if we had a three way union,
we would get a similar
expression, except that here
we would have, again, a
product of three terms
instead of two.
So now, let us put to use what
we have done so far.
We are interested in the
probability that the outcome
falls in the union
of three sets.
Now, an important fact to
remember is that the
probability of an event is the
same as the expected value of
the indicator of that event.
This is because the indicator is
equal to 1, if and only if,
the outcome happens to
be inside that set.
And so the contribution that we
get to the expectation is 1
times the probability that the
indicator is 1, which is just
this probability.
Now, the indicator of a three
way union is going to be, by
what we just discussed, 1 minus
a product of this kind,
but now with three terms.
Let us now calculate this
expectation by expanding the
product involved.
We have this first term, then,
when we multiply those three
terms together, we're going to
get a bunch of contributions.
One contribution with a minus
sign is 1 times 1 times 1.
Another contribution would
be minus minus--
that's a plus--
X1 times 1 times 1.
And similarly, we get a
contribution of X2 and X3.
And then we have a contribution
such as X1 times
X2 times 1.
And if you look at
the minus signs--
there are three minuses
involved-- so, overall, it's
going to be a minus.
Minus X1 times X2.
And then there is going to
be similar terms, such as
X1 X3 and X2 X3.
And, finally, there's going
to be a term X1
times X2 times X3.
There's a total of four minus
signs involved, so everything
shows up in the end
with a plus sign.
So the probability of this
event is equal to the
expectation of this random
variable here.
We notice that the
ones cancel out.
The expected value of X1 for an
indicator variable is just
the probability of that event.
And we get this term.
The expected value of X2 and
X3 give us these terms.
The expected value
of X1 times X2.
This is the indicator random
variable of the intersection.
So the expected value of this
term is just the probability
of the intersection
of A1 and A2.
And, similarly, these terms here
give rise to those two
terms here.
Finally, X1 times X2 times X3 is
the indicator variable for
the event A1 intersection
A2 intersection A3.
Therefore, the expected value of
this term, is equal to this
probability.
And, therefore, we have
established exactly the
formula that we wanted
to establish.
Now this derivation that we
carried out here, there's
nothing special about
the case of three.
We could have the union of many
more events, we would
just have here the product of
more terms, and we would need
to carry out the multiplication
and we would
get cross terms of all types
involving just one of the
indicator variables, or products
of two indicator
variables, or products
of three indicator
variables, and so on.
And after you carry out this
exercise and keep track of the
various terms, you end up with
this general version of what
is called the
inclusion-exclusion formula.
So the probability
of a union is--
there's the sum of the
probabilities, but then you
subtract all possible
probabilities of two way
intersections.
Then we add probabilities of
three way intersections, then
you subtract probabilities of
four way intersections, and
you keep going this way
alternating sings until you
get to the last term, which
is the probability of the
intersection of all the
events involved.
And this exponent here of n
minus 1 is the exponent that
you need so that the last term
has the correct sign.
So, for example, if n is equal
to 3, the exponent would be 2,
so this would be a plus sign,
which is consistent with what
we got here.
So this is a formula that is
quite useful when you want to
calculate probabilities
of unions of events.
But also, this derivation using
indicator functions, is
quite beautiful.